so steve's tour did you go to preston
and say like hey man i'm putting
together this tour you want to come on
or like how did that come together i
asked him to go on tour for sure 100 of
that it was um
i mean the the old tour started with the
this shady rave promoter
who uh invited me to come out to a party
with bam and we man and then like
it just turned into like me being an
attention horn doing stunts and he was
like oh we'll make a show out of this
and
we started booking the show and uh
clearly the shady ray promoter guy
thought it was a more saleable show if
it was more guys from jackass so i don't
think you even got an opportunity to ask
to come on because dunlap was looking
for people to uh to recruit
and so the most of those tours would be
the two of you don and we man i mean it
was it was always me and then two other
guys from jackass okay and dude check
this out
the the story that i got that we all got
i think was the that the our all don't
try this at home tour was was uh sold
for a lump sum of ten thousand bucks
and and uh i got three thousand bucks
each of the other two jackass guys that
were on the show
got fifteen hundred bucks a piece so
that takes you to
six thousand and then the story was well
they gotta pay for airplanes and hotels
and everything but whatever's left over
after that
uh dunlap gets to keep that's the shady
promoter guy yeah now there's uh
there i mean it would call me shady i
think he would have called himself a
shady promoter i've been proud of it
yeah yeah we're very proud of it but
you know
we definitely never got any money for
merch and there was like
there was merch flying all over the
place and we didn't see any of that
and
now that i've been touring
for
like a lot of years i kind of understand
it a little bit better
like you don't get
you don't sell a show for a lump sum you
get a percentage of the door and we were
doing shows that had like there were
there's definitely i remember a show
that had 3 000 people oh yeah for sure
thousands of people
you don't sell you don't you don't sell
thousands of tickets for 10 000 bucks a
lump sum right
how much for ticket prices usually at
your shows
20 bucks right
so guys ohio was on the side of that
hill or mountain out there thousands of
people there yeah so so i'm thinking in
retrospect
that
you know like i got 3 000 bucks you know
preston got 1500 bucks like whoever else
got 1500 bucks but i'm not even mad
about that because
had i been making that kind of money
back then it would have been good for me
i don't think don't know huh dangerous
yeah
man
have you have you ever heard from him at
all i ran into him at a bar or something
in l.a he was completely super nice i
had the best conversation with him not
long ago
you know he was just talking about i
asked him about how that all worked and
stuff he said it was just a fax machine
business he said you just sent faxes and
waited for him to come in you know did
the different venues and stuff right
right you send out taxes and get faxes
back in i mean to be fair nobody
like in the legitimate entertainment
industry wanted to [ __ ] with me
or any of us you know like that this
this
rave promoter was like the best we were
gonna get and
you know to his credit he carted us all
over the damn world man he made a big
deal out of us some places you want to
go for sure yeah yeah i mean you guys
went to europe you did all sorts of [ __ ]
yeah extensive tours in europe yeah one
of my favorite things was when i was uh
in amsterdam
swallowing uh
a condom full of weed to smuggle it
into switzerland and you're sitting
there
i got in the weed and i plopped into my
mouth and i just swallowed it down and
you said well you can just swallow that
that easy
sucking all that park dick paid off
the best
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]